misses the three Curry up ahead green
with the catch James with a foul and
Draymond Green goes down hard
[Applause]
here's here's the pass coming up as we
see Draymond Green on the floor Curry
looking up again a shot from the top
contested by green and he runs out hit
his head on the floor coach he sure did
and he's still down
yeah just the Snapback oh right there
and it was oh
my question from a coaching standpoint
though is anybody on either team going
to rotate back defensively when somebody
shoots the ball from the top of the Kia
we're just going to stand there and
watch and let the guy who contests it
run to the rim
oh
so we'll take a a time out here Scott
Foster is going to the monitor
and just just looking at a potential
clear path I think is what they're
checking on green did of course have a
step on LeBron James did LeBron make a
play on the ball
but uh on the fall just to snap back on
the hardwood that that is a scary
situation and
it just can't be too careful
any kind of Blow To The Head like this
he definitely was trying to get to the
ball saw he wasn't going to be able
pulls his hand back down but he's going
for the ball initially there's no
question he's making a play on the ball
I hate to see that kind of fall
I mean no injuries do you like to see
but the head is uh there's a separate
thing you always worry about concussion
brain injuries those are things that can
affect you in the future the thou has
been deemed to clap common foul the
defender made a legitimate play on the
ball which by rule is not a clear path
the voice of Scott Foster
well and we know how to determine that
Scott Foster was right on that because
he agreed with me that's right so you do
have an incredible streak going yeah I
haven't missed since October I don't
think I had a bad one I think the first
game of the year that wasn't your fault
well again what I have pointed out is
that when I'm not correct on the way the
call is going to go it's the referee you
make a mistake he's just trying to help
yes we do have a Kane Fitzgerald if we
need him tonight he's back in the replay
Center I appreciate Kane being there for
us as well
[Music]
Draymond Green still